[Music]
good evening everyone thanks for coming
over I hope you're having an exciting
day today we understand it's been a long
one and we are all very keen to go and
head to the after party so we will try
it and make this one of the most
memorable sessions of the day for you
throughout the day you would have been
hearing about the benefits of cloud and
how the need for speed agility scale and
ease of deployment is required in
business today in this session we are
going to talk about app modernization
and app migration but also link it to
how to enhance the end-user experience
in the way globally we are seeing a
trend in organizations where they're
thinking about the end user experience
before they think about the technologies
that are needed to power those
experiences we call this an outside-in
thinking Woolworths is a shining example
of this outside in thinking mindset
Woolworths is a largest retailer in
Australia and they have been able to
provide their consumers with the
seamless omni-channel experience
irrespective of the channel that they
are accessing the Woolworths services on
whether it's web app mobile app or even
Google cloud or Google home rather my
name is Poorna Bhattacharya I have been
with Google for the last two and a half
years and with Apogee for six years
prior to that throughout my journey I
have played a variety of roles right
from engineering to consulting to
leading the sales engineering team today
the charter of my team is to accelerate
our customers success on the platform
and provide them business value on the
platform as soon as possible I'm
thrilled to have with me on stage
Joshua Rogers from Woolworths Joshua to
you hello everybody I'm Josh
I am the platform technology manager at
Willie's ex I just started there about a
year ago and I'm keen to help them on
their cloud journey and we're gonna go
over some of that today sure thanks Josh
so let's quickly go over the agenda for
the day for what we are going to cover
in the next 45 minutes we'll start with
the various parts that organization can
take to move to the cloud and modernize
their technical stack on the way we'll
talk about some of the key challenges
that we have learnt in our journey with
multiple customers globally and how can
a P eyes and API management help
mitigate some of those challenges Andres
Josh would then take over and talk to us
about Woolworths journey of providing
their consumers with connected
experiences and then provide specific
examples of how they have modernized
their technical stack and migrated some
of the key workloads to the cloud we'll
finish the session with our ami channel
demo and an architecture associated with
it
by the way Josh and I both have flown
all the way from Australia and to make
the session more interesting we decided
to share some Aussie fun facts with you
throughout the session so pay attention
a quick reminder throughout the session
please feel free to add questions on the
Dory app go to the go to the next app
click on the session link and add
questions throughout the session at the
end of the session if we have time we'll
answer some of those questions
if not we'll make sure that we get to
each one of them offline all right let's
get started any organization needs to
decide their cloud strategy based on
multiple parts that they can take on
moving to the cloud organisations can
decide to lift and shift their workloads
into the cloud and then modernize it or
they can decide to modernize on-prem
and then move to the cloud very rarely
do we see organizations just moving to
the crowd without an aspect of
modernization associated with it but any
organization would have to decide one of
these parts Beit Shean based on the
workloads that they are migrating and
the consumers of those workloads
migration is never easy it takes time
sometimes months sometimes even years
irrespective of the path that's chosen
for migration api's and API management
can make sure that the path towards
moving to the cloud is made easier next
let's take a look at some of the common
challenges that we have seen our
customers face through the various field
engagement survey we have worked with
the customers globally or the surveys
that we have conducted the first and
foremost challenge that any organization
faces is business continuity migrating
to the cloud should not disrupt the
existing user experiences that an
organization has and those can be
external experiences over web or mobile
apps it can be an partner in experience
or even your internal employee apps
that's the first challenge the second is
of course security when workloads are
migrated to the cloud the data
invariably lives in multiple places are
and are being accessed through multiple
channels making sure that this happens
in a secure way a drink to the
compliance requirement and the best
practices that your organization has set
up is vital the third challenge is
visibility there are some key questions
that any organization faces during the
migration to the cloud how's the
traction of my migration which work
have migrated to the cloud which are
still on promis-- are my own promise up
still getting traffic from consumers or
can i deprecated them or decommission
them answers to these questions are key
to take some business decisions in an in
any organization the fourth challenge is
interoperability the new or modern apps
which have been Reap lat formed and
moved to the cloud many times don't want
to access the legacy protocols that the
legacy apps might expose also the onus
of talking to a different kind of
back-end whether it's modern on legacy
should not lie with app developer the
app developer in this case are our
consumers because this will make their
apps more complex they would have to
write conditional code based on whether
they are connecting to a modern app
versus a legacy app so that's the fourth
challenge the last challenge is
unmanaged services moving to the cloud
invariably results in two or most of the
time results into a micro services based
architecture while we understand the
value of micro services based
architecture there might be unmanaged
micro services which can cause security
challenges duplication of code or
unintended behaviors with me so far
good introducing Apogee Apogee is a full
lifecycle API management platform
I can talk about Apogee for the next few
hours but for the purpose of this
section I'm going to just restrict
myself to the features of Apogee that
will help us in mitigating the risks
that we spoke about in the previous
slide Josh in his section is going to
cover some of the high-level key
features that will words as leveraging
of the platform today so here on the
left-hand side you see the various
end-user experiences which are exposed
through web or mobile
these are your end customers on the
right you see the back ends or the
system of records these system of
records can be on micro-services it can
be a node.js app it can be an app on gke
or even a legacy monolithic application
the largest the biggest challenge that
any app migration faces is the tight
coupling of the user experience with the
system of Records or the exposure layer
and the consumption layer so Apogee
provides a layer of abstraction between
these two worlds ensuring service
connectivity and making sure that the
apps whether they are the front-end
workloads or the backend workloads can
be migrated without disrupting the
existing user experiences we spoke about
the security challenge Appaji can act
both as a security mediation and a
security enforcement layer so as apps re
platformed and modernized the protocols
and the security mechanisms that they
leverage might be different than the
legacy ones the modern apps might use
protocols or mechanisms like Joe token
or Roth and the legacy apps might be
leveraging basic authentication or sam'l
Appaji provides uniformity by exposing a
single security mechanism to the apps
while mediating the credentials between
the legacy and the modern apps
Appaji can also provide security checks
or enforcement's like regex checks or
data loss prevention checks when GCP
when the on-premise workloads are
calling workloads on the cloud the third
aspect was visibility because here
Apogee acts as a facade between the
on-premise and the cloud workload
it has the required visibility on how
the migration is progressing
what's the traction on migration and it
can tell us give us the data like which
are the api's or api products that are
leveraging newer backends which are the
ones who are leveraging legacy backends
have all the traffic moved to the new
backends so that I can decommission my
legacy applications this allows the
platform and the product owners to take
business driven decisions that are
needed for any organization the fourth
challenge that we spoke about was
interoperability the reality is that not
all apps can be migrated at once which
means that there'll be apps which have
been Reap lat formed and modernized and
moved to cloud which instant needs to
talk to legacy backends or there might
be newer apps that are being written
today and they might have to talk to
different both legacy and the new
backends Apogee helps by providing an
API facade which can do the required
transformation like soap to rest and it
takes an out the necessity for the AB
developers a modern apps to have
conditional code or download specific
libraries to talk to let's say a soap
back-end moving on the last one was
service management left shift and
modernize is a common way of migrating
to the cloud and many organizations
leverage micro services often on Kuban
at ease to achieve the same now while as
I said while we are aware of the
benefits of the micro services driven
architecture the challenge is as an
explosion of micro services in an
organization we need the right security
and visibility to make sure that those
micro services are adopt adopted across
the organization to prevent any
duplication of code or security
loopholes
is theö is a common way to manage this
which acts as a service mesh Appaji acts
an additional API management layer by
providing security protocols like orth
or additional analytics for
organizations who are not leveraging as
Theo or micro gateway Apaches Micro
Gateway provides the similar
capabilities with that I come to the end
of the first section so we spoke about
the various paths towards migration the
top five challenges that organizations
face on modernizing and migrating to the
cloud and finally we spoke about how can
API is an API management helped mitigate
some of those risks now before handing
over to Josh I'm going to give you the
first aussie fun fact of the day
Australia is an island nation it has
more than 10,000 beaches so if you were
to visit one new beach every day is
going to take you 27 years to visit all
of them who wants to get started thank
you thank you partner
alright so now I'm going to introduce
you to Woolworths wool versus a customer
of Apple G's Morris was founded in
Australia in 1924 they started as a
small location called
what were stupendous bargain basement
and as they continued to grow and spread
throughout the or Australia they
developed a nationwide presence around
1960 they were soon on their way to
becoming a household name come February
1998 they launched home shop which is
ecommerce for groceries and it was one
of the first in the world to offer
groceries fresh to your door after the
after ordering online there was a couple
other group businesses who also
endeavoured online during this time as
well
wool versus a combination of a lot
smaller businesses and each individual
business had a concentrated effort to
establish an online presence
individually so as these businesses
continue to evolve and new technology
becomes available our websites that were
once hosted in a private data center
we're lacking access to the technologies
and we were fastly getting outpaced so
with that developed an opportunity for
us to migrate into the cloud not only
did we want to lift and shift like parn
I had spoken to before but we also
wanted to modernize it and it's not your
regular digital transformation it's also
a supermarket at nature trying to enter
a digital market so in order for us to
accomplish some of these digital feats
the Woolworths group started combining a
few of our efforts and establishing a
holistic customer experience by way of
Woolies X Woolies X is a combination of
engineering and business professionals
that concentrate on the customer
experience at the forefront of every
decision that's made you can see here we
have over 500 team members and 400
customer service agents working to make
sure that our team understands the needs
of our customers things that we've been
able to accomplish in the few short
years since this organization was formed
are we are up to 11.5 million
Rewards members so to give you a little
context there's only 24 million people
living in Australia so we're nearly half
of every half of the population is a
Rewards member another quick fact is
there's only about 12,000 households or
sorry 12 million households in Australia
so we're 1 for 1 in every household not
particularly high school but numbers was
some other things to note we are do over
two billion dollars in transactions and
that's quite a big number when we're
talking about a supermarket that's
moving online
so how do we get started on Apogee we
had the need to connect our consumer
applications with some back-end services
that were not particularly owned by us
we had applications that need to connect
to third-party services and we also had
employee apps that need to connect to
our HR services we started with two
businesses six developers bill 15 api's
and was handling around 45 transactions
per second
Appaji helped us streamline the
developer experience a couple of the key
features that partner wasn't able to
speak into are the developer portal the
developer portal allows you to create an
API key and understand the contracts
that are established between our API s
and you as the consumer the consumer
doesn't have to be an internal employee
it can also be an external consumer and
that's one of the things that we want to
make sure that people understand is
anything that's good enough for your
internal teams should be provided as
good or even better for your external
and similarly anything that you're going
to deliver at high quality for your
external consumers you should treat your
developers with the same level of
establishment some other things that
really benefit us are permissions the
granularity of permissions on the Appaji
platform allow us to get down to
delivery of the application to
production traceability of those
transactions during live messaging as
well as visibility into analytics and
controls that help safeguard our IP eyes
API is abuse prevention in the way of
appaji sense allows us to capitalize on
Apogee's ai and ml models to identify
anomalies and any other malicious
behavior and stop it before it gets to
our systems and this is a key thing for
us to make sure that our customers
themselves are getting a consistent
experience no matter who's being
malicious on our network an additionally
API monitoring allows us to make sure
that our traffic patterns are where we
expect them to be if we see an increase
of five hundreds over a
period of time we can alert ourselves
over email slack or even a customized
web hook and those web hooks can be very
powerful to integrate with any of the
systems that are not on boarded into the
Apogee platform one of the other key
things that I want to mention is parner
as well as other of our accounts and
support engagements at Apogee have been
along with us every step of the way and
have been critical for our success on
the platform so with our success we
unlock new business opportunities some
of these are business ventures that
capitalize on just an abstraction
between the customer and our back-end
services and don't offer anything in the
way of really adopting or spreading in
those data it's spreading data between
the services other services are fully
connected into each other via data so
our internet service our credit cards
and financial services and gift cards
those are all services that are
brand-new and we're trying to explore as
a company later on we'll build out the
technologies establish them ourselves
but the presence on Apogee will not
change we'll try and keep that contract
as consistent as possible
scanning go which is a new innovative
customer experience for our stores
allows customers to walk in find the
goods they need scan them with our phone
and complete the checkout process
themselves they don't have to walk
through our checkout lines or deal with
any of our employees they can just
create their own experience within our
stores
Woolworths online also reaches almost
half a million customers actively and we
run our mobile applications throughout
the day to make sure that again our
customers gain a consistent experience
when integrating with our services and
then down in the bottom right you see
rewards Rewards is a critical component
to collecting that customer experience
data and making sure that we can consume
it and then respond to it we can take
the rewards data and integrate it with
every single one of our services because
the availability that we have on Apogee
so we continue to grow we now have
reached over ten businesses internally
we have more than 18 developers actively
developing on api's
evolution the modernization the
governance of those api's we trying to
keep them up-to-date and making sure
that all 1,000 of our available api's
are up to the same standard as we want
and now we transact over 480 times a
second on all of our IP eyes and that's
something that we've peaked quite a bit
quite a ways higher but it is without a
hitch so as with most growth there
becomes a few challenges there's an
evolution new opportunities arise and
I'll talk to you about one of our
opportunities to migrate from a database
as a service to GCP cloud sequel all of
our back-end ancillary systems deliver
large parcel of data into a blob storage
and then we utilize triggers to transact
that data and load it into our databases
Apogee acts as an abstraction layer so
during the development of scanning go
our product that I was telling you about
we needed to move the data from our
database as a service over to cloud
sequel our database as a service was
operating in an account that we didn't
have full control over we didn't have
the ability to react or permiss any
additional resources so in order for us
to continue to grow and expand our
operations we needed to take content
control into ourselves so we utilized
Apogee to continue that contract of our
customers while we make those back-end
changes so a lot of that learning that
we had to do is still with a very new
organization we're only a year and a
half in at this point and we were able
to do it with the support of Hana and
the team at Apogee to redevelop our
loader scripts within Google we were
able to move the data over preemptively
we're also able to test and go through
all of the scenarios to make sure that
our applications are going to respond to
the new data store and we were able to
do it with only a 30-minute window of
execution special thanks to Terry Shyam
on our API team our business teams or
QAS
and the support staff who made sure that
we were diligent about every aspect of
this migration
so now we'll transition to another
Aussie fun fact and we've added on this
slide the crest from Australia a good
fact about the kangaroo and the emu are
they cannot walk backwards and so
there's a bit of meaning test to why
they face each other on the crest so now
I'd like to introduce you to olive all
of us our virtual assistant that we're
developing outside of our cognitive
Technology Services team all of is able
to analyze customer inquiries align
their intense with actionable work for
our workflows and then take that data
package it up and present it back to the
consumers in a consumable way we have
features like our store locator and
hours of operation we also have features
to modify your lists manage your
shopping lists and answer any frequently
asked questions that you might have
so what I'll talk to you through is a
quick demo of our olive platform so I'm
gonna focus on our Google home
integration mics back on sorry for the
loudness
all right so ok Google talked to
Woolworths
sure
let's get Woolworths welcome to Wally's
how can I help you today
what's my nearest store to find the
address for your local store I'll just
need to get your current location from
Google is that ok yes the address for
Woolworths Wagga Wagga is 87 Bayliss
Street vulgar Wagga New South Wales 265
Oh is there anything else what time do
they open
Woolworths wagga wagga at 87 Bayliss
Street is open today from 7:00 a.m.
until 10:00 p.m. is there anything else
what's on my shopping list your shopping
list is empty would you like to add
something add milk to my shopping list
I added milk would you like to add
another item to your list wanna be Ozzy
without Vegemite
I added Vegemite would you like to add
another item to your list some Tim Tams
I added symptoms would you like to add
another item to your list doesn't
understand my American accent sorry no
sorry
would you like to add another item No
can I help with something else no thanks
for speaking with the fresh food people
good bye so there's a quick introduction
to our coordinated services that we're
trying to develop and the key factor
there is we have back-end services that
have data that the customers want to
have access to and they want to be
comfortable accessing that data they
want to be able to interface with our
business in the ways that they're most
easily available to them so one of the
things that we did there was talk about
our shopping lists and so I'll switch
over to my laptop which will show you
our website and on our website I've
already logged in I can just walk to or
sorry click on my lists go to my Google
home and you can see I added symptoms to
my shopping list I'll just go ahead and
remove that first the other thing that
we have integrated into our website is
the ease to take something that was
spoken and then turn it into a search
just by clicking on it you can scroll
through the results find the one you
want
quickly add it to the cart and then
continue with the next step your next
item
and do the same we'll go with the
drought relief milk help up the farmers
and then continue the checkout process
from there Thanks switch back to the
slides and so how are we able to
accomplish this we started with a very
simple task to make sure that we take a
real customer impacting event as well as
a real business impacting event and we
married them together our customers call
up our customer hub and they want to
know specific information information
that's very readily available but they
don't have any other way to get it
calling up our customer hub takes up
time there's a lot of other activities
that our customer hub endeavors in that
take up a lot more time than they
probably need to so we utilize our voice
integrated with dialogue flow we work
with our applications that are hosted
within gke we then operate through
Apogee to our back-end services to find
the data that we need to deliver the
experience that we want funnel it back
into our applications in gke which
prepares it for delivery to the customer
our chat bot is able to connect to our
customers via hangouts a chat bot
virtual assistant on our website you can
call us up on the IVR or speak to us on
the Google home and we utilize the same
architecture oversimplified for this
illustration for all of it and that
allows us to expand even more into
answering and connecting with our
customers in a digital way we want to
make sure that it's not just our
Woolworths online experience that they
have access to but also our BW s our Big
W our Dan Murphys our money and
financial services and we want them to
be comfortable and connect to us in any
way that they would like over facebook
messenger alexa's homes digital
assistants of any kind and I think that
that brings us to the end so we can ask
any questions if you guys have
thank you there are a few questions on
the dory but before that if anybody has
a life question we can take that first
couple of questions on the dory about
could we get access to the recorded
presentation absolutely I think it will
be added to YouTube
in the next few weeks the slides are
also going to be prepared as a PDF and
available as well yeah all right the
next one good Apogee API be used for
monitoring service service management
incident management escalations so
Apogee acts as a abstraction layer or a
facade which means that Apogee can be
leveraged for monitoring your API is SLA
s and s loz and it's in fact that's
something which will verts uses
significantly Josh you want to share
your experience with API monitoring yes
we we utilize API monitoring to make
sure that our back-end services
understand what scale of traffic is
coming through the platform when we're
caching on the front-end or within the
apogee layer it's not always clear a
small change that introduces entropy or
dynamic city into the requests how much
of an effect that might have if it's not
able to cache it on that layer so we
want to make sure that we're very
cognizant of how much traffic is flowing
through Apogee and we utilize alerting
and different dynamics there's multiple
different dimensions available to
measure to alert us of any changes in
the in the transactions as well
absolutely question from Allstate a few
lights and uploads for the that one do
you think that so this is for you Josh
do you think the adoption of Apogee and
API management and product and
production ization of api's by bullies
help crew or increase revenue if yes can
you please elaborate on that yeah
absolutely because
we want to make sure that we have that
consistent customer experience across
all of our businesses and what that's
going to do is generate a bond with our
customer it's going to set some
expectations and they're going to feel
comfortable transacting with us so the
immediate revenue increase is to make it
available for our customers to shop or
interact with our services on a variety
of platforms but then the long-term
increase of maintaining that customer
retention is also beneficial thanks Josh
the next one again for you somebody from
Delta Airlines again upvoted a few times
could you talk about the API development
roadmap used at valise eggs how the
api's were identified was that a
business driven top-down versus a
project driven bottom-up approach to
develop and deliver api's yeah
absolutely so the necessity for data to
become available should be the first
thing that you consider when you're
developing your services it's not
necessarily the data that's valuable to
you but the data available for other
services to integrate with you
especially in a distributed micro
service world you want to make sure that
you're not having to modify the
contracts to provide the data that
somebody might need to make a business
transaction possible one of the
situations that we've ran into while
establishing a virtual assistant was we
didn't necessarily have access to the
data that we wanted to improve the
customer experience things like what
time will my order be delivered so we're
constantly working on enabling
integration and putting that at the
forefront of a lot of the business
decisions that we make
when first designing those services yeah
it's always a combination of both but
understanding that what are the
consumers of your API is and making sure
that you identify and then work
backwards from there has is usually a
good recipe yeah absolutely the next one
from Optimas again a lot of uploads for
that how do you determine bad consumers
what advice would you give to a
government entity looking to leverage
Apogee
first of all leverage Apogee absolutely
and if you have questions come to the
Appetit booth downstairs but handed you
over to Josh how do you determine bad
consumers so you repeat the question one
more time how do you determine bad
consumers I guess this is from an
external and user perspective from our
sense I guess from what detection right
so Apogee sense provides us a bit of the
bad actor detection and we're actually
it doesn't ever reach our systems
themselves we were able to get a report
on what transactions have been blocked
on the apogee layer and then react to
those if we wanted to try and date a
mind to make sure that we're analyzing
the traffic patterns that are the
opportunities that people potentially
might explore with other api's that
don't process the refugee there are
opportunities for us to go back and
analyze those reports to see which ones
are actively being actioned as well as
any of the traffic that comes all the
way through Apogee provides an
opportunity for us to analyze the data
themselves our sorry data from those
transactions as well so if we do see
something that may have made it through
Apogee sense we're still able to go back
and try and identify some of those
traffic patterns and and utilize our own
defenses at that point yeah and
especially in the case of Woolworths we
have seen how geolocation there is the
originating traffic that has helped
quite a bit like you don't expect people
from Asian countries to put online
request on Woolworths in Australia so
geolocation again a part of Apogee sense
has helped quite a bit and again we do
have a lot of government entities who
are apaches customers a lot of security
patterns that we have been able to
establish so definitely worth the chat
whoever has posted that question quickly
moving on we do have time so yes we are
doing fine in your experience what are
what are your most critical patterns and
anti patterns for API driven development
yeah I think I touched on it a bit
earlier and
you never know the data that's going to
be consumed until you go to utilize it
and it's not there you want to make sure
that you're trying to identify the best
ways to vend the data in a protected
manner but make it available for
internal consumers and in some cases
external consumers to identify the other
thing is to make sure that your
developers know very well how to version
an API forms a contract before between
consumers and services and if we don't
version it properly features or data
might not be available the next time
they call your service if you and we
want to make sure that internally every
contract that we commit to maintains the
same level of inputs outputs and data
formats as we once committed to all the
way through the lifecycle which leads me
to the next point which is know and
establish a deprecation policy make sure
that before you put it something into
production you know exactly how you're
going to go about taking out our
production as well when the validity or
lifecycle of that service is over I
think those would be the three things
that I would absolutely and again Apogee
has a has published a book recently and
it's technology agnostic on
anti-patterns best practices around API
so maybe I'll put a link to the enter
the Dory question later on a question
that's getting a lot of votes is how
many poisonous snakes are in Australia
there's a ton of poisonous tail not I
think this is time for both Josh and I
to also share a secret both of us are
kind of fake Australians I'm an Indian
and josh is an American but yeah but
loads right yeah absolutely there's a
ton of a ton of creatures out to get you
in Australia
how does Apogee work with multi cloud
environments this is a good question a
few comments there do you have a
federated API gateway that's a great
question
yes Apogee hybrid is some
which we are announcing as part of next
we would be able to provide API gateways
which can run in any you know near to
your data center and multiple locations
with a single control plane to to know
more please do visit the apogee booth in
the expo area but a short answer is yes
even with multi cloud I think as it was
mentioned in the keynote today we do
know that most organizations will have
multiple clouds just like Woolworths and
we do have the ability to work across
multiple clouds with our hybrid offering
it's a good question there thank you Oh
somebody put a comment saying we have
multiple cloud situations and so far
Appaji has worked well so thanks Glen
for putting the comment there we do have
few more time for few more
where do your apogee alerts get routed
to involve words does it use web hooks
to call pager duty I think we are
getting deep into details now or send an
email directly or does it feed into a
bigger system for alert management so
Apogee sense itself provides you the are
you not sense API monitoring right
monitoring yes API monitoring provides
you the opportunity to specify email
address slack integration and books web
hooks as well as pedra duty integration
natively so you can work your alerts
into those systems things that I would
utilize web hooks for would be executing
maybe a service Wow incident or some
other incident management's to try and
get you a bit more of a record on your
incident management systems that
Appaji can tie into another question
from Delta Airlines rajeev was your API
development centralized or distributed a
great question again how did the org
adopt to api's was there a separate
governance team to build and enforce
standards
so they caught the question around
centralization versus distribution we
utilize a central team structure and my
developers themselves are actually
integrated into the squads so we utilize
the central team to form a community
around api's and best practices
governance and then also to share
knowledge around what has worked and
what has caused challenges but the
developers themselves actually operate
strictly within the businesses so it is
quite the decentralized model in that
sense yeah and usually our
recommendation when we work with
customers is to start maybe with a
centralized team to ensure that the best
practices and the governance is being
put in place and then as the as you
mature and the API program matures it
makes sense to have a decentralized team
and we call it governance with a small G
which means that the idea is to enable
the team to innovate and leverage the
platform rather than act as a as another
gate there but yes absolutely I think we
have seen multiple customers follow the
same route that will work sells to and
through can you speak to Apogee
deployment model in use at Woolworth's
are you using Apogee cloud on promoted
so right now we operate solely on cloud
services yes within Apogee that said we
are working with the engineering teams
at Apogee to be one of the early
adopters of the hybrid cloud looking to
see how it fits into our current cloud
operations and permissions models and
structures so the way that we organize
our services within GCP is going to be
different within the way that we
organize within Azure and we want to
work with Apogee to make sure that it's
comfortable when we move Apogee into
those different cloud providers and so I
would say that it's a it's a primarily
on cloud we utilize the tools that are
provided for us and then in the future
we're going to be utilizing more of a CI
CD delivery model to each individual pod
that we deploy for Apogee
sure another question on can you let us
know what sort of API versioning
features are provided and leveraged so
this is part of the API design itself
yeah and what Apogee provides you with
is a few different environments that you
can set up to stage any of your
production changes before you get them
to produce all the way through your
pipelines to production within each
stage you're getting access to every
single version a version is actually an
Apogee sense a set of artifacts and once
that set of artifacts has been uploaded
to the platform it's available to be
made into a production service or made
available on any of those environments
and it's very quickly to demote or
promote one of those versions into an
operation the actual management of the
versioning of the API should be done
within your code and then delivered to
the system in a way that allows you to
manage which ones are currently in
production without affecting any of the
other deployments that you've already
made maybe this is the last question
that we take now yeah we're running up
on time Eva yeah be running out of time
soon
how do you engage with external app
developers and how did you achieve
better engagement and participation
again a key part of any API program is
engaging the app developers both
internal and external so each one of our
external app developers goes through our
business-to-business team and the
business-to-business team has a core
function to establish that relationship
but as you can imagine the developers
are not part of that transaction usually
so a lot of our documentation is
available via the developer portal for
the api's that we make available for our
external consumers the adoption of it
though is driven by an active
conversation that we maintain between
our developers or external developers
and our internal developers we provide
an opportunity for them to get together
and actually discuss any of the
challenges that the external consumer
might come across and then also work to
make
sure that we address them yeah and we
have seen organizations have a specific
rule around evangelism both internal and
external and hackathons play an
important role to make sure that your
API is a well known internally and even
expose it to the external consumers so
events like hackathons actually help
alright with that thank you again for
staying back let's head to the
after-party thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]